حتى بالنسبة للبلدة التي أمضت معظم
العقد الماضي على حافة الصراع،
فهذه صور مذهلة في وضح النهار
تكشف عن مساحة واسعة من الدمار في
بوكروسك مع استئناف جهود الإنقاذ.
يقول رئيس البلدة، على بعد حوالي 30 ميلاً من الجبهة الشرقية، إن اثنتين من قذائف سكاندا
الباليستية  سقط الصاروخ بفاصل 37 دقيقة
مساء الاثنين، هذا هو
السيناريو الفاشي الروسي القياسي، 30 إلى 40 دقيقة
بين الصواريخ عندما
وصلت خدمة الطوارئ الحكومية ورجال الإنقاذ
لإنقاذ الناس، سقط الصاروخ الثاني،
وبالتالي فإن عدد الضحايا يزداد
هنا لحظة التقاط تلك الضربة الثانية
على كاميرا جسد المسعفين، من
المثير للدهشة أن العشرات من
ضباط الشرطة وعمال الإنقاذ كانوا من بين
الجرحى وكذلك الأطفال الذين قُتلوا
نائب رئيس خدمة الطوارئ الحكومية
في منطقة دانيتسك
بعد أن شهدوا الضربة الأولى، حيث
سقطت هذه المرأة البالغة من العمر 75 عامًا ضحية للضربة
الثانية  في شقتها الخاصة
كان هناك تأثير أول لم نتعرض للضرب،
كل شيء كان على ما يرام هنا كنت أتحدث على
الهاتف وأنا جالس ثم فجأة طار هذا
وسقط من حولي ثم
سقطت النافذة علي ظهري وقد جرح
فندق الآن مغلق  كما قصف مطعم إيطالي كان
يرتاده صحفيون أجانب ذات يوم، ونفت
روسيا استهداف
مناطق مدنية، وقالت يوم الثلاثاء إنها ضربت
مركز قيادة عسكريًا أوكرانيًا في
باركروز، ولكن بعد مرور ما يقرب من 18 شهرًا على هذه
الحرب، أصبحت مثل هذه الهجمات مكانًا شائعًا،
وتقول أوكرانيا إن روسيا لا تتخلى عن
الجبهة.  سطور إما لقطات تم نشرها في
نهاية هذا الأسبوع تظهر وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجي شويجو وهو يزور على ما يبدو
مواقع نادرة داخل أوكرانيا،
في ختام أسبوع تقول أوكرانيا إن
روسيا أطلقت فيه ما يقرب من نصف مليون
ذخيرة في الشرق،
كما أخبر مسؤولون غربيون شبكة CNN لمدة
شهرين في إحاطات حول حالة
أوكرانيا  يتزايد التشاؤم بشأن الهجوم المضاد
حيث لا تزال
القوات الأوكرانية تواجه طبقات من
الدفاعات الروسية في الجنوب مع وقوع
خسائر في الجبال. بصيص ضوء،
الدفعة الأولى من دبابات أبرامز القتالية الأمريكية
جاهزة الآن للشحن ومن المقرر أن تصل بحلول
أوائل الخريف على الأرجح لا.  في وقت قريب بما يكفي
لتحويل دفة الأمور في الهجوم المضاد،
لكن هناك دفعة معنوية لأوكرانيا تحت الهجوم مرة أخرى